[Musik]
alle alle im ida mini serie mein name
ist luca die peek at the moment den ich
in der szene allerdings auch wenn es der
stress sind günstig den bunker herren
bei den damen und herren darf ich euch
heute ganz herzlich begrüße es eine
episode luca die picasso reagiert auf
die beste 3d zeichnungen in die ganze
welt starten wir mit diesem mit 3d
street in einem amerikanischen großstadt
nehmen einfluss es wir sehen ein
wasserfall ein wasserfall zusammen mit
vielen leuten die sport machen ich kann
das persönlich auch ganz easy
nachzeichnen ist meine nach zeichnung
von der diese zeichnung von julie und
max wochen wir allerdings direkt weiter
mit dieser zeichnung es ist eine würfel
die schön gezeichnet wurde auf einem
blatt papier lukin 8 und dicaprio dies
zu kann das doch für mich auch eher vola
ist eine wunderschöne würfel gewordenen
das hier ist er die nächste zeichnungen
man sieht es sieht aus wie ein bürger
stärkt die abgestimmt in würde und man
kann dort runter den sand sehen es ist
überhaupt kein problem für lugano
dicaprio es sieht so aus meine damen und
herren sie können essen kaufen für 17
millionen euro unterm emission hier ist
die nächste bild von eine tolle
streetart zeichnungen wir sehen ein auto
abgestürzt auf einen brücke und auch ein
fahrradfahrer der auf den weg in sein
tod ist das bietet von edoardo reja ihre
kinder nur die cabrio kann ist natürlich
auch direkt schnell nach der wohl als
zeichnung von nokia ovi cabrio warum
mache ich ja gerade seine schauen wir
uns die nächste klasse 3d zeichnung an
und zwar ist es eine hand meiner lieben
freunde auf einem blatt papier
allerdings wird das blatt papier
zusammengeklappt und dann wurde
allerdings auch was ausgeschnitten also
sieht extrem kratzfest dass hier von
alessandro de die und das muss die firma
damit muss verdammt glücklich nochmal
einmal kurz nachzeichnen dies sehe eine
ganz normale zusammengeklappte papier
und wenn man allerdings auf klappt sieht
manche und das kunstwerk einer
wundervoll gezeichnet in hand mit einem
ring drehen
kobi dem einer lieben freundin schauen
uns jetzt wirklich mal weiterhin diese
extrem krassen 3d zeichnungen an uns war
es dass sie das nächste
das hat jemand in london bezeichnet das
sind leute die an einer eiswand hängen
und dort hoch klettern und das hier
finde ich bemerkenswert weil es nicht
irgendwie von einem krassen künstler
großstadt ist sondern irgend so ein
junge hat das gezeichnet in seinem
hinterhof allerdings habe dem heutigen
video ja schon gesehen wir haben nicht
nur extrem krasse irgendwelche heftigen
street zeichnungen irgendwo in
großstädten die teilweise auch
gesponsert sind von großunternehmen
sondern auch so was beispielsweise von
mohammad el gmail sprachen lernen da das
ist die nächste klasse 3d street
zeichnung und zwar ist es so eine kleine
pfütze die gezeichnet wurde und es soll
so aussehen als würde der asphalt dort
ein wenig abgesenkt sein
allerdings ist das halt nicht der fall
sondern es ist eine zeichnung weiter ich
kann nicht mal das haus vom nikolaus
zeichnen das ist das haus
vom nikolaus liefke 4 und jedes video
channel 4 und trading karlsruhe avo wie
macy das hier ist allerdings wirklich
meine favorite street zeichnung die wir
im heutigen videos anschauen werden uns
war es eine person also einmal nach
rechts der sich selbst links gezeichnet
hat und sogar auch das bier da
hingestellt hat beziehungsweise auf der
anderen seite das bier gezeichnet hat
wirklich nicht er wie gesagt ich kann
nicht mal haus des geldes sagt
wahrscheinlich kann ich nicht aus das
geld ist zeichnen oder die nächsten drei
krassen street zeichnungen sind
zebrastreifen und zwar sieht es hier
halt schon so aus als würden die teile
schweben hier sieht es auch so aus und
da stehen sogar noch leute drauf und
hier sieht es so aus als beherzt ganze
eingebrochen
kommen wir jetzt zu einer person die den
eiffelturm gezeichnet hat und das ganze
sieht so aus ich versuche jetzt mal
normal den eiffelturm zu zeichnen ein
paar sekunden später
ich zweifelte und wahrzeichen von
frankreich hier seht ihr eine elefanten
der auf ein blatt papier gezeichnet
wurde allerdings wurde dort nicht nur
der elefant rein gezeichnet sondern es
sieht wirklich so aus als ob er aus dem
papier aus keltern und deswegen wurde
daneben auch noch so papierschnipsel
hingelegt und es wird voll krass
gezeichnet ich habe unnormalen respekt
vor solchen leuten auch so was das wurde
einfach über drei papiere gezeichnet
weil wir das so groß gezeichnet hat das
hier finde ich halt auch besonders krass
ist von edgar müller
der hat auf seiner riesigen am meer von
riesigen paypal hat er halt einfach so
was nettes gezeichnet klingt auch erbost
doch so viel farbe das nächste ist gar
nicht mal so ein riesiges will die
gerade beispielsweise von edgar müller
das ist wirklich gegen die 50 60
quadratmeter groß ist dass er da
gezeichnet hat sondern das ist extrem
klein und zwar ist das ein kleiner fisch
es ist so ihre auch das hier
ich meine das bisher waren ja alles
irgendwie so vernünftige gegenstände
gegen wie der eiffelturm so sachen wie
man wirklich vorlagen hat aber bei so
was braucht man halt auch mal eine menge
fantasie oder auch bei sowas klar man
kennt krokodile aber eine vorlage von
einem krokodil das so aussieht als ich
meine das bild jetzt von vamos a der hat
extrem krasse oder auch dass hier das
jetzt mal was komplett anderes also es
ist nicht komplett irgendwie auf einer
straße gezeichnet und so weiter und so
fort sondern hat quasi auf
pro kasten hat er einfach dahinter das
gezeichnet wie es aussehen sollte also
vielmehr mit natur und nicht so grau und
dann so ein kleiner fluss halt auch mal
eine krasse message die leute da
teilweise verbreiten hier finde ich zeit
besonders kraft ist das wirklich nur auf
einem blatt papier gezeichnet ist also
nicht irgendwie auch zwei stücke zieht
wirklich eins hoch sondern es soll
einfach nur so aussehen und das hier das
ist dass es eh so geisteskrank diese
street zeitung ist von leon care und das
ist auch eine meiner absoluten favoriten
für das heutige video weil man nicht nur
der streetart mäßige sieht sondern also
wie es einfach runter geht da keine
ahnung was sondern er hat mehrere ebenen
mit drin
zum beispiel hier rechts so das sind 3
verschiedene ebenen
es sieht extrem crazy aus beim nächsten
bild finde ich halt extrem krass das
wirklich mit schatten et cetera
gearbeitet wurde also nicht die
perspektive sondern auch wirklich mit
den stadtführungen krass rum gespielt
wurde und zweitens dass hier also sieht
wirklich so aus als ob die person dort
steht und die menschen einfach klein
sind sie hält die person in der hand und
hier ist halt der schatten und das finde
ich halt heftig weil das licht auch
wirklich von da kommt also da haben sich
die leute so große gedanken gemacht oder
auch das hier so dass dann musste
erstmal drauf kommen er hat es mit einem
college block gefeiert das heißt die
andere seite liegt eigentlich die ganze
zeit unten für das bild das jetzt
allerdings hoch gehoben
wie machst du das wie kann man so ein
krasses perspektivisches denken in
seinem gehirn haben oder auch hier das
ist auch wieder hochgeklappt die seite
eck kommt dir klar wo ich allerdings
überhaupt nicht klar kommen würde wäre
wenn ich das hier aus dem flugzeug sehen
wird da hat einer auf eine häuser dach
extrem riesige spinnen gezeichnet bruder
ich habe schon angst wenn ich so eine
kleine spinne mein bart sehe was ist
soll ich denn dann erleben wenn ich im
flieger sitzt und das ja das ist für
mich extrem süß und zwar ist es ein
alter stillgelegter brunnen und ihr seht
schon rings herum liegen halt so kleine
quadratische backsteine in der mitte ist
allerdings sonja so ein runder kreis
eine kreisförmige platte und da der das
halt so drauf gezeichnet wird es dort
als wird dort runter gehen und so ein
kleines monster wird halt irgendwie raus
gucken und das hier bin ich halt auch
krass aber ich weiß nicht ob das nicht
sogar einfach irgendwie darauf gelegt
wurde das jetzt allerdings direkt das
nächste und zwei dinosaurier der aus
einem blatt papier ausgehen konnte den
zeichne ich jetzt mal nach jeder muss
wie auch immer ich hätte mir könnt ihr
gerne auf instagram schreiben wenn ihr
eine bild haben wollten
preise gehen los simuliert in quarantäne
macht mich langsam verrückt ich wünsche
ich könnte hat auch so krass zeichnen
wenn ich jetzt raten der quarantäne wird
den ganzen tag einfach nur zeichnen das
hier ist von carmen harada und das hier
ist halt auch so krass allein das hier
unten
dass er noch so licht rauskommen das ist
ja wahnsinn
der süße plate ein wenig geärgert gerade
von mir und meinen mal diensten wie der
allerdings werden die ich es auch
nachzeichnen
dadurch soll das ist das bild nicht ich
werde es mir selbst nachzeichnen
doch freude wir schauen jetzt hier die
letzten 3d zeichnungen noch respektvoll
zu ändern von daher erstmal dass hier
wieder von edgar müller extrem krass und
auch wieder sei riesig also ich weiß
nicht wo der typ die ganze farbe her
nimmt man ihr das machen aber okay aber
das hier so dass dafür brauchst du
wirklich einfach nur ein bleistift und
es ist so ihre allein die idee mit den
händen die dann dahinter zu packen und
dann auch das dass das papier dann nach
rechts eingerissen ist wo dass er das
ist einfach krass oder auch das hier das
ist halt dass das ist ja nicht mal groß
aber es ist trotzdem so kreativ und kraß
einfach
manchmal wünschte ich hätte auch ein
paar talente
das an das ist ein vater mit seinem mit
seinem sohn dir deine person im sommer
in die innenstadt eine art pool
gezeichnet und hat dort sogar so flip
flops leben gestellt und coca cola
daneben gestellt und so weiter und so
fort und das hier hat auch eine person
in der innenstadt gezeichnet er sieht
das ist wahnsinn das ist von julie frost
ich dach gerade die bilder von edgar
müller wären riesig und dann habe ich
das hier gesehen
das ist doch locker 100 meter lang das
bild aber gute liebe freude kommen wir
jetzt auch schon zuletzt in 3d street
art zeichnung fürs heutige video uns was
ist das hier
es ist ein mädchen mit ihrem vater und
der vater hat auch ein loch in den boden
gezeichnet und hat dort kanalisationen
rohre et cetera hin gemalt wo die beiden
sich drauf gestellt haben
das heutige video hat mir wirklich
gezeigt dass deshalb dass ich wirklich
überhaupt nichts kann an der stelle wird
di luca die capriati studios heutige
video allerdings auch beenden - gefallen
hat dann lässt sie gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da und ihr
könnt ihr meine kanal abonnieren und
hier ist eine weitere video verlinkt ich
kann euch diese abonnieren vor allem
wenn ihr noch keiner bund inside mit
nicht nur sehr einsetzen liegen
modernisiert der nicht zeichnen
supertolle würfel dinosaurier und auch
dollar leichter